when you saw John Ross beat the four to  four high emoji that he sent out soon as  he ran the time remember that official  time hadn't came in and he tweeted I  emoji was there all of you that was like  I hope that gets corrected and it's  actually a four to five probably a part  of me bastard still for today I don't  believe he beat it you round up or two  to know when you look okay for once when  you look at the okay I put it off on  them at the end right  that's fast yeah number two is when have  it ever took that long for the time they  take a long time you're right  Wow that it was rigged  they proudly made with your shape Riley  got tired of tired of Joe never  highlight although yeah they probably  got tired of nowhere being there fare  like that the compound was getting  boring they needed more attention either  more it senses all the conspiracy theory  guy this is one of the best ones I've  ever heard I'm telling